dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Jean affair the 2016
rio olympic games is right around the
corner so it is the perfect time to talk
a bit about how we can use science to
predict the results before we start I'd
like to mention that we won't be
showcasing any predictions for this
year's Olympics instead we are going to
talk about the model that was used to
predict the results of previous Olympic
Games events so the following very
simple question arises can we predict
the future and the answer is very simple
no we can't end of video thanks for
watching well jokes aside we cannot
predict the future itself but we can
predict what is likely to happen based
on our experience of what happens so far
in mathematics this is what we call
extrapolation there is also a big
difference between trying to extrapolate
the results of one athlete or the
aggregated number of medals for many
athletes usually an entire nation to
bring up an example about traffic if we
were to predict where one individual car
is heading we would obviously fail most
of the time however whichever city we
live in we know exactly the hot spots
where there are traffic jams every
single morning of the year we cannot
accurately predict the behavior of one
individual but if we increase the size
of the problem and predict for a group
of people it suddenly gets easier going
back to the Olympics will Usain Bolt win
the gold on the 100 meter sprint this
year predicting the results of one
athlete is usually hopeless and we
bravely call such endeavors to be mere
speculation the guy whose results we are
trying to predict may not even show up
this year as many of you have heard many
of the Russian athletes have been banned
from the Olympic Games our model would
sure as hell not be able to predict this
or would it we'll see in a second but
hopefully it is easy to see that macro
level predictions are much more feasible
than predicting on an individual level
in fact to demonstrate how much of an
understatement it is to say fee
visible hold on to your seat belts
because Daniel Johnson a professor of
microeconomics at the Colorado College
created a simple prediction model that
over the past five Olympic Games was
able to achieve ninety-four percent
agreement between the predicted and the
actual medal counts per nation what is
even more amazing is that the model
doesn't even take into consideration the
athletic abilities of any of these
contenders Wow media articles report
that his model uses only five simple
variables a country's per capita income
population political structure climate
and host nation advantage now I'd first
like to mention that GDP per capita
means the gross domestic product of one
person in a given country therefore it
is independent of the population of the
country if we sit down and read the
paper which is a great and very easy
read and you should definitely have a
look it's in the video description box
so upon reading the paper we realize
there are more variables that are
subject to scrutiny for instance a
proximity factor which encodes the
distance from the hosting nation not
only the hosting nation itself but its
neighbors are also enjoying significant
advantages in the form of lower
transportation costs and being used to
the climate of the venue unfortunately I
haven't found his predictions for this
year's Olympics but based on the
simplicity of the model it should be
quite easy to run the predictions
provided that the sufficient data is
available the take-home message is that
usually the bigger the group we are
trying to predict results for the lesser
the number of variables that are enough
to explain their behavior if we are
talking about the Olympics five or six
variables are enough to faithfully
predict nationwide medal counts these
are amazing results that are also a nice
testament to the power of mathematics I
also really like how the citation count
of the paper gets a big bump every four
years I wonder why if you are interested
in how the Olympic Games unfold make
sure
to have a look at the Olympics reddit I
found it to be second to none as always
the link is available in the description
box thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
you